[موسيقى]
هذا يأتي على
[الموسيقى]
يهيمن عليه الذكور بشكل
مؤكد وهو نوع من الترهيب بالنسبة
للسيدات للدخول في
بعض الأحيان
والإعجاب بأشياء من هذا القبيل ولكن في الآونة الأخيرة
ظهر عدد أكبر من النساء لذا
فقد أصبح الأمر أكثر  من المريح للمرأة أن
تأتي وتمارس
[موسيقى]
ما لم أشعر به من
أن
الناس لا يريدونني
في المجموعة لم أعطه هذه
الفرصة لتجعلني أشعر بهذه الطريقة
التي تعرفها والأمر يتعلق بالشخصية
إنه يتعلق بكيفية  أنت قوي
إذا كنت خجولًا إذا كنت تفعل أي شيء
بسبب
ما ترتديه ،
فأنت تعلم أنه يجب عليك التحقق من
نفسك بهذا مثل لماذا إذن لماذا
ترتديه
من حيث
ما يقوله الناس
أنني تجاوزت ذلك كثيرًا  ماضي جدًا
أنك تعرفه لأنك
تخيل
لو توقفت عن ممارسة الباركور ، استمعت عندما
يقول الناس
إنني الشخص الذي سأكون بائسًا
كما لو أنهم سيستمرون في المضي قدمًا في
حياتهم ،
فأنت جيد
أحيانًا فيما يتعلق بالثقافات  مثل
الآباء العرب خمسة  أنا أحب
التقييد لما
يريدون أن تفعله بناتهم
وما هو مختلف عن والدي هو
ذلك لأنني أنا أكبر
طفل
أم أنه كان دائمًا
أم سارة ، ستكبر
وستتكبر  كأن تكون مستقلاً ،
ستعرف أن تطور عملك الخاص ،
فأنت تعلم أنك يجب أن تكسب أموالك الخاصة
حتى لو أمي هي نفس
الشيء الذي تعرفه وكأنك يجب أن تكون قويًا ،
عليك أن تضع قدمك في مكانها وكن
واثقًا  من حيث أكون اليوم كما لو
كانوا دائمًا دائمًا
يدعمونني دائمًا
[موسيقى]
إنه عنوان أمتلكه منذ فترة طويلة جدًا
وأنت تعلم أن المضي قدمًا يبدو كما لو أنني
لا
أريد أن أكون معروفًا بهذا الاسم فقط
لأن أي شخص  يمكن أن تكون
رياضية محجبة في الباركور ، لكن هل
يجيدون ما يفعلونه ،
أريد أن أظهر أنني بالتأكيد أكثر
من ذلك
[الموسيقى] ،
فهذا يجعلني أشعر بالحرية ، وهذا يجعلني أشعر أن
الاحتمالات لا حصر لها ويمكنني فعل
أي شيء
[  موسيقى]
أنت